hey there everybody and welcome to the
Shawn method I'm sha mcginness this is
Maxwell McGee rubbing his eyes in
preparation in preparation for all the
dino combat that we're about to take
part in courtesy of The Stomping Land
which is in keeping with kind of a
tradition on the show a open world
Multiplayer Survival game on Steam Early
Access cuz apparently on Early Access
apparently I just have to play every
single Multiplayer Survival steam Early
Access game on this show that's like my
new life goal it's important to set life
goals reasonable goals for yourself and
to work towards those goals as part of
your self-actualization exercises well
one week at a time we're finally going
to get there last week it was the forest
this week it's The Stomping Land and if
you're not familiar with the Stomping
Land this game's Hook is dinosaurs it's
got dinosaurs in it uh aside from that
it's kind of it's kind of like rust in a
way in the fact that it's you know open
world survival you're collecting
ingredients you're crafting buildings
campfires things like that um but this
one obviously is uh dino themed so we're
going to it gives you the option to do a
solo campaign but then it warns you
right off the bat this is kind of a
shitty idea you should go back and maybe
try some multiplayer a little boring
yeah maybe boring so we're going to jump
into
online it came out on Steam Early Access
a couple months ago now I don't want to
overwhelm you here Sean but I really
feel like you might want to go with
survival mode for this one yeah I feel
like that's kind of that's kind of the
hot mode right now kind of kind of the
hot mode people are people seem to be
into it so you'll notice that lot of
zeros out of 16 there's not a huge
player population and the reason it
seems to be is if you look at the the
user reviews on
a little bit of a backlash against this
they are not necessarily the kindest
reviews um and I was looking there's a
Reddit page for this game up as well and
it seems like it hasn't been updated in
a really long time so a lot of the
threads are just theories and
speculation about what the where did the
people go why does nobody working on
this game anymore yeah I mean in terms
of in terms of Early Access games this
one's on the expensive side it's $25 on
Steam so it's yeah no it's definitely an
investment compared to other games that
are out there uh like the forest which I
think we played last week I'm pretty
sure that one's like
$15 um so yeah I mean so obviously as
the price scales up you're going to need
to uh deliver more content and this game
is it's a little sparse at the moment
but we're going to see what's in here so
uh because this is a multiplayer
survival game the very first thing that
we're going to do is chop down a tree so
let's that's why don't we go ahead and
do that as you can see I'm kind of like
this this tribesman type dude uh I got
my little loin cloth thing got some you
got some sweet tats that we can't quite
fully appreciate yet in the warm glow of
the Moonlight but I'm sure we'll catch
more of those later I don't know if the
sun is coming up or going down right now
yeah we were you folks folks who weren't
able to see before the show started we
were Sean and I were involved in in in
an intense game of is the sun coming up
we're going down um and as you can see
the debate is ongoing we may never
actually reach a conclusion as it is
always going to be foggy Twilight 247 so
here's one of the interesting things
about this gameb andj wants to know
where in waterfall okay where in
waterfall waterfall all right good good
to know so one of the one of the things
that makes this game slightly different
from other uh Multiplayer Survival Games
is the way the inventory system works
particularly when it comes to crafting
so I can hit the space button and you'll
find that there's like this screen
that's not super helpful to me right now
it doesn't actually give me any options
for things that I can craft or things I
can paint or anything like that that's
because when you chop down a tree it
gives you a little piece of wood but you
can't carry more than one of them you
have to stuff them into this little box
right here which gets progressively
bigger as you stuff more wood into it
and from here I can craft a torch if I'm
so inclined um or I can pull it over
this way
as you can see yeah in this very very
nice little Prett much how would happen
yeah I mean if I was a caveman with a
pet box and I was taking it out for a
walk this is more or less how it would
look right I mean that's just I mean I'm
no Anthropologist but I'm pretty sure
that's how it would work people in the
chat are coming that it is a bit dark
out in the game is there perhaps a gamma
option oh you could crank up wicked high
oh good we're going to go on a journey
here full screen well we can do it in
full screen or why try I'll try let me
try to join a daylight server why don't
we try that well you mean join the other
server the other server that that's the
one I was just in one wasn't I think hey
this is a PVP Village something
something something one of the fun bugs
about this game is that if you jump out
of a server yeah uh you CP back out to
the main menu it won't let you jump into
another server until you exit the client
and load it back up
so oh and now that one a boo super cool
why don't we try one of these really
high ping servers down here maybe we'll
see if anything's happening in Europe
there you go there you go let's try that
one I bet it's daytime in Europe CU
that's how it's all different time zones
you go over the equator and it's like 4
hours and it's daytime yeah I mean I've
been the here we go hey there we go
hopefully that helps you out chat a
little bit brighter all right a little
bit brighter hopefully it's going to be
a little bit more visible for you so I'm
going to resume my crafting process
because I start out with just this
little axe right here and uh trust me
I've tried to kill dinosaurs with this
axe not super
useful so what I'm going to do is I'm
going toy is true to life in that way in
much the same way that you would drag a
box to the beach it would be quite
difficult to defeat a dinosaur with but
a humble Hatchet it is what I would call
a hardcore dyo
simulator uh which you know it's it's
unforgiving it's brutal it's rewarding
in its own complexity I wonder if one
day in the the far future when dinosaurs
have been cloned into living beings
there's going to be like a a a specialty
blog dedicated to going back and playing
games like this and seeing okay how
closely did they were they able to
emulate what it would actually be like
cuz now we know they definitely got our
modern-day crafting system spot on we do
like to chop down pieces of a Tre
straight I like it going straight into
that Boulder just rail on it just give
me those Rock on that Boulder that's
what I'm doing man your freaking
hatchet's the real hero of this game I
feel like that thing would just snap
like a twig after the first two or three
all right so I'm going to make a
spear this spear is what's going to help
me take on these
dinos you trust me on that one is this
progress bar going to take like 600 hour
oh this thing's done okay don't worry
about that all right so I'm going to
find me some dinos I'm going to spear
them to death is what I'm going to do um
maybe I should see what's going on with
the uh Universal
chat you need to say where that party
at oh my my my initial thing already
expired nobody's talking in this this is
like a fully populated world but
nobody's talking that's fine I don't
need to talk to people to kill dinosaurs
there's dinosaurs literally roaming
around the place do you think I should
make a shield for defensive
purposes I mean I don't know how much a
shield would actually help you against
freaking D what kind of dinosaurs you
think you're going to I don't know the
kind that that can be taken down with a
shield maybe I feel like we need to
fight the dinosaur first and get some
Intel get a sense all right we need to
get a sense for what kind of challenge
we're facing and then we can re-evaluate
I like we want to build the shield or
not that seems like a real good idea
we're gonna go find a Dino and then
we're gonna kill it and we're going to
use that Intel to determine whether we
need to craft anything else or if the
spear really is the golden gun in The
Stomping Land which may or may not be so
Sean I've noticed you have uh you have
the eyeball over there on the side of
your screen you also have zero uh green
circles I have zero green no twig and
berries no twigs and your meat is all
grayed out my meat is all grayed out
you're it seems like you're in a real
sorry State I am definitely in a sorry
state do you think that's a player down
there uhoh I see do that's that's a
human silhouette if I ever saw one that
could be a human silhouette that could
be a dino silhouette it could also be a
rock we're going to go find out that
would definitely be the worst op also I
just want to show you real quick how my
character runs which is hunkered real
low to the ground real low and a real
wide
stride all right that is a Dino and you
know we're going you know what we do to
dinos stop here we go we kill dinos stab
them up what up you're oh oh you're dead
wow yeah that yeah
talk about you all right you can say
You're Gonna you're gonna you can make
the claim you can make the claim that
was anticlimactic which you're perfectly
within your rights to say however bear
in mind I am Nature's ultimate Dino
Hunter so in reality I thought the
dinosaur was going to obliterate you on
site I thought this was a horrible idea
but you just one shotted that dinosaur
and turned him into two delicious steaks
which then transmuted into a box oh yeah
and you know what I'm going to do I'm
going to cook those steaks cuz I'm a
hungry Dino Hunter hungry Dino Man
hungry dino man that's how that's how
things worked in the prehistory times
Well in the future you know you have
those Hungry Jack frozen dinners you'll
be able to buy your hungry Dino mans
once the dinosaurs have been cloned so
while I'm uh Building A Fire here tell
me how the chat room is doing uh they
were excited about the possibility of
fighting a dinosaur until the moment
that I just until the moment it just got
instantly
obliterated um of course people pointing
out that this is why the dinosaurs W
extinct yeah because apparently you a
butterfly could have tackled that
dinosaur and he would have just topped
over what is that supposed to mean come
on you give me a little bit of credit
would you I'm going to make a fire pit
and I'm going to cook this meat so I
mean does that how most of your Dino
encounters no there there are definitely
bigger dinosaurs in this game
I make a fire pit come on give me more
wood this is always the most fun part of
live streaming any Survival game game is
the part where you just it's the
anticipation it's like oh I think I need
Stone actually oh
yeah when I lived out in the country I
uh we you know we'd build a fire and you
know if the fire started getting a
little low you just pick up some rocks
Chuck them in there and uh you know it
fans the Flames yeah the Rocks
definitely the Rocks uh I think it might
be getting night time I don't know that
was kind of an Abrupt transition it's an
Abrupt transition it really sneaks up on
you in this game all I know is that I'm
going to get some Stone how much stone
do I need to get I got my crafting guide
right over here oh I've got a craft fire
pit is two wood two Stone oh what i cho
down like 10 wood two ston all right you
can also
do other things build a totem why would
I want to build a totem and then pray to
it I'm I'm just going to the dino gods
that they may bless you with the
strength of the dinosaur I'm the teeth
of the dinosaur I'm trying to pull my
Dino box what come on come on Dino Box
come on boy get over here just going to
do this you're just going to you're just
going to draw two more wood yeah cuz I
don't need to drag it over there I I got
a you only need two wood and two Stone
it's like the easiest thing you can
build a tee with tinwood which you're
probably almost there no I'm going to
make a fire pit there we go wow and then
I'm going to cook that Dino meat and I'm
going to use that energy to go take on
other dinos when you uh when you kill
something and consume the meat that uh
imbues in you the strength of whatever
you killed absolutely it works with
Dinosaurs it works with animals it works
with uh other things that aren't
dinosaurs or
animals uh small meat I'll take that
thank you just going to run around with
my small
meat man that daytime cycle did not last
too long did it it yeah you got rocked
on the daytime cycle hey you guys in the
chat room if you want me to quit out and
join a daytime server just let me
know there we
go all right going to start a fire check
this out meat you did it cooking that
meat you did it yeah you got to
tenderize it now I got to warm myself
warm yourself M yeah the thing is your
Lo the thing is hunting it's good for
potency yeah this is this is an old uh
caveman trick if you want to become a
more viral dinosaur hunter what you got
to do is really smoke your junk that's
right just really get it if you really
want to be a king of the tribe yeah you
need to have a uh a slow roasted uhhuh
tackle box down there it's like making a
fire hardened spear tip that's right
that's right it's forged in the flam so
that it's even stronger than you started
it's like that basic idea but for your
genitals but for your genitals instead
of say a sword or a piece of metal oh
there you go here we go this one's
really good too little uh look at this
this is the ultimate form of uh stealth
I
think you have to be the fire we're
going to eat this small meat eat small
meat all right gobble gobble here we go
you did it great did it I ate that small
meat and my little your meat icon is
still still totally almost non-existent
now yeah the the interface in this game
is
uh yeah it's not it's not the best like
right now people were really excited
about the whole wooden box thing you had
going on but look at this pass now I got
is it is it daytime now is it is it are
we playing a game called Daytime
Nighttime I think it is night night it's
hard to tell the transition the
transitions in this game are really
abrupt and when it starts raining
it suddenly gets really light out but
then it stops raining and it gets dark
out again mouse Madness in the chat
pointing out that you were roasting your
chestnuts pretty good that's pretty good
that's pretty good that's not bad that's
not bad that's not bad at all so uh
dinosaurs also toasted
bunsa you do it do it do it circle stra
circle stra the dinosaurs are ready for
those like what Quake two tactics or
what dinosaurs can't handle Circle
strafing can't handle that Circle stra
that I'm not even going to eat this meat
I'm just going to throw it into the
water come boom don't even need that
meat CH the waters and a dinosaur shark
is going to come and Gobble you up it's
the ultimate insult
dinosaur your meat's going in the water
your meat's going in the water I don't
care about your meat I just wanted to
kill you for the sport of it all right
we some bigger dinos that's right now oh
now you got that you got that adrenaline
rush you think you're all hot stuff now
I am hot the dinosaur hunter oh yeah
slayer of dinos where's more dinos we
need a big Dino we need we need we need
it to be daylighted is there are there
Dino dungeons in this game you know what
I'm going to do with the king dinosaur
waiting at the bottom I'm I'm going to
make an executive decision I'm going to
quit out to a daylight server roasting
your pork and beans it's too dark it's
too
dark I will see however if they let
me Darkness simulator 2014 definitely
not letting me all right so that was I
killed some
dinosaurs I I killed some dinosaurs you
did yeah
and that's what happened so far on this
episode of the Sha method playing uh The
Stomping Land which is super early which
is so far uh darkness and dark box
simulator 2014 oh yeah uh all right
we'll see if one is daytime now I really
feel like you could just Join one of
these empty servers we've had very
little personto person interaction just
in case that moment arrives Maxwell I
want to preserve the Poss you did you
did get butchered so before the stream
started Sean did get butchered by a
random person out on the Beach that was
pretty
exciting yeah that was great we'll see
if that happens again are there dinosaur
fish are there fish dinosaurs I
definitely saw something swimming in the
sand like literally it was a fin in the
sand sand it
was Sand Sharks Sand Sharks that's like
prehistoric Street
Sharks we go you ever watch that show
what show Street Sharks Street Sharks is
that like that show Shark Tank it was a
poor idea is what it was but an awesome
show all right this is happening I'm
going to make another Spear and then I'm
going to take Chey wooden box what what
do you have against the GD wooden
boxes oh this game is uh yeah this is
definitely it's definitely a video game
yep
yeah here we
go oh people want to see the Bola hey
wait wait wait whoa this guy this guy
this guy get out of the menu this guy
okay here we go he's he's after your Bo
my [__] he's after your box he's jacking
your box bro come on come on get him get
this dude mess this old boy up get your
box okay your box is want piece this you
want a piece of this he's got that wide
stride he's running he's bailing for it
get the spear get the spear oh God hurry
hurry he's coming back he's coming back
he's coming back he's throwing the ball
at you Sean you got to hurry oh you got
to hurry oh no am I getting captured oh
you're getting captured you got to go
you got to go I'm going to crawl into
the ocean call to the ocean mother ocean
will rescue you oh you are in a pickle
why did I try to C
never going to be enough time to craft
that Spear and now I'm a human
trafficking slave you are yes you are
being this is TR you are being human
traffic is that how prehistory went I'm
not even like I can't even anything he's
taking you to his buddy his buddy is
dragging a box around this is going to
get real oh may maybe he's he's going to
save you just oh and he immediately got
captured get up get up get up can you
not get out of this bolo oh he butchered
your friend and now he's taking you oh
this is so
my friend oh no type some things into
chat all right I'll type some things in
maybe you can uh maybe you can strike a
deal with them tell them you have a
bunch of gold you can capture no just
let it just okay me but I have to warn
you uh-huh I don't do no wait just stop
it I have to warn you and then keep all
right now keep
typing you don't you're going to say you
don't do but
you I don't do butt
stuff why are you why where is this man
taking me you are on Parade right now
human slave traffic he's doing a whole
zen garden thing with him he is a am I
like his R oh you're going to his creepy
Hut he's taking you to his creepy murder
Hut although there's another guy over
there maybe they know each other maybe
they don't May maybe this guy will try
to come and help you it looks like he's
got you uh on display
there I don't think the other guy sees
you oh no no he's going for it he's
going for
it oh this is all right here we oh BS B
get away get into the ocean get into the
ocean going into the ocean wait turn
around and look what happened turn
around it's
see even if one of them died now we have
no way of knowing if it was the good one
or the bad one I'm going to the ocean go
to the ocean all right swimming with the
fishes that's right I'm
hiding the
stealth sorry [__] all right so
here's this
guy is he going to come after you is he
not going to come after you no I think
is he confused he's like where'd you go
oh wait are you progressing your way out
of the this is how I get out of my human
traffic situation okay here we go we
need to go all right it's it's Vengeance
time it's mle Gear Rising Revengeance on
this
guy guy was trying to take me to his
little shitty Fort think I'm going to
let oh are you the dude wait wait wait
wait wait wait hold on we have
to who's this guy oh you are just being
a real son of a [__] right now aren't
you yeah this guy he's a guy who tried
to kill me you think I'm going to let
him get away with that just working that
back there you need to make some bolos
for yourself bolos seem to be the cruise
control
for let me murder this guy first all
right just give me a minute I'll yeah
you just uh you do that it's going to
happen
I don't think I'm murdering him
something's something's happening oh
what where this guy come
from one shot spear revive me bro are
you going to come on no you're dead can
you please revive me you're dead you're
just dead that's fine you know what we
finally have a situation going on here
we do we got a there's a little bit of
drama brewing and uh all right you need
to get you some wood some rocks all
right time to make a spear so you need
reng on these people all right two Dr
really far though I wonder where he is
but you need to be prepared you need
bolos BOS is should I go bolos should I
try to human traffic somebody you should
try to human traffic somebody uh bolos
are two wood one
stone let me make a spear first and then
I'll make a bolo as my backup weapon all
right whoa oh wait a minute whoa is I
missed where that bolo come from I
missed it it's getting a little uh whoa
oh it's getting get squirly oh this guy
follow me zigzag motions Serpentine
Serpentine motions hit him with tactical
menus tactical
menus it's that spear dude that spear
that spear is real Spears are real in
this game revive
me revive Peter Brown is playing
BioShock Infinite for some reason oh
what get to get to work Peter Peter get
to work you sad son of a [__] Sad Sack
all right this is I think basically oh
oh this is going to happen he's ready to
receive a tackling from
you oh he's bailing he's bailing on your
whole yeah my first kill but not my last
can do you think I consume his meat
consume his man flesh it won't let me
consum tonight we Feast on man flesh it
won't let me consume his man
flesh all right well you got one kill
under your belt if I had to pick my
least favorite part about The Stomping
Land it's probably that I can't consume
man flesh you really need to be able to
do that you get those cannibal Powers
you get all weird in the head cuz you're
a cannibal you should attach a note it
won't let
me that's one of the many dead ends in
the interface system of The Stomping
Land you might be presented with the
option to attach a note but then the
game is like f
note I can congratulating you for your
sweet murder oh yeah that that murder
felt real good I'm not going to lie to
you that was uh
people want to know if you can well
actually sidb bird 19 want to know if
you can build a saddle and ride a
dinosaur into battle I think you can
ride dinosaurs but you have to kind
of I forget how it works you have to
like subdue them with some kind of like
special plant I think which is only
found in certain caves but you know
what's not found in certain caves these
sweet Bolas I got here and I'm going to
go is a a dinosaur taming section of the
wiki included with a picture of a dude
riding a dinosaur all right well there
you go all right so do you remember
where that guy's human traffic Fort was
it was on the beach was it on the beach
it was on the beach next to a river well
if this game is anything like Day Z then
people always spawn on the beach so
there's a good chance I'll encounter
somebody and I can make them my human
traffic what you need you need a healing
herb cuz you kill the dinosaur you have
a healing Herb in your inventory you
give the healing herb to the dinosaur
and you're like sorry and then you'll be
able to mount it by interacting again
inter which sounds lwd that sounds very
lwd is that a person or a tree in the
distance to obtain a healing herb you
have to find a cave and in the cave you
explore it and find the healing her
sounds pretty
dope let's see oh where's some people
where the where the party at where that
party at where that party at should I
ask my chat room
yeah it's weird is you have to open the
chat dialogue and then click the chat
dialogue and then say don't question it
where that party
at come on guys where that party
at and then your chat text like
immediately
disappears within five seconds almost
Cove where where's the Cove chat room do
you guys know where the Cove is guide me
I will rely on your intelligence all
right I'm ready to receive Cove
instructions yes tell us where it is
otherwise we're just wandering through I
feel like I need to craft a spear you in
case I run into an actual Dino cuz right
now I have this weird little Bolas thing
your bolo thing is going to be able to
my bolo tie is not going to cut it
unless it might I don't whoa unless you
be looking good Oh I thought that was
like a trap or something all right we
got some Stone here this thing kind of
looks like a Cove maybe I think this is
a CO have water all right we're going to
craft how much stone do I need for my
spear Max well uh it's two and two two
and
two people are not being super helpful
with their directions to the co all
right what are they saying uh the best
one lead we have so far is uh a what the
Cove might be close to the beach try
running along the edge of the beach um
otherwise otherwise it is mostly
nonsense directions let's see spear is
two Stone and five wood oh was you're
leading me astray shows what I know
that's the last maybe it was the Bolos
that were two oh that could
be all right get my spear
out here we
go it is five- two you're right it's
four- one for the shield
or 5716 to build everything okay here we
go so I got my Bolis I got my spear I
got this Lake and I got a really angry
player population and practically no
dinosaurs so welcome to The Stomping
Land Early
Access oh yeah this
yeah it's a it's an interesting game is
what it is I mean the thing is like I
want this game to be really good cuz
dinosaurs are cool as hell mhm they are
they are tight as hell but you know
what's not cool as hell this game right
now
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah all right we're going to find some
kind of dinosaurs that's what we're
going to find there's got to be
dinosaurs around here right I mean
you're near a water source you think
there would be dinosaurs need need water
yeah they do so is it always raining in
this game
no it just rains a lot I
think all
right what's that old saying follow a
river follow a
dinosaur is that how it goes I think so
right you grew up in Arkansas you know
about you know that's what the the
pilgrims would say when they follow a
river follow the dinosaur when they came
to the new world and they were exploring
the untamed and they thought it was all
going to be sea monsters and and and and
dinosaurs and what the hell else oh I
see some dinos over there oh uhoh here
we go here we go ready game time going
to start with my exercises my stabbing
exercises warm up those stabbing arms oo
okay oh is there dinosaur tussle look
like a Dino fight is there a tussle oo a
dino
tussle is that a dead Dino you think I
can Feast upon it I think that's just a
rock oh there's definitely a dinosaur
there's definitely going to be a dead
there's one dead Dino over there now oh
there's another dinosaur getting it you
need to get in on this is that you need
to get in you need to weigh in on this
situation oh and he's distracted he's
distracted by the Dino fight there you
go oh this is so good this is so good so
good where is he going he's bailing
go catch up with him go into the woods
com for you buddy oh he's bailing so
hard for you buddy he's bailing so hard
on you I have no idea how to use these
bullets wa did he just go up that tree
no that's like a weird that's just the
worlding in I don't see him I don't see
him this is bad we're losing this is bad
should I go back for the dinos M you've
shut off your targeting computer what's
wrong oh no okay uh yeah go back to go
back to the Dinos he's gone back to the
din he's
gone let's
see there's some good so one of the
things is that there's two different
types of Dino meat in this game there's
big meat and little meat little meat is
from the dinos that you can kill big
meat is from the Dinos from man flesh
that only the big dinos can kill oh and
apparently that's more
filling yeah look at this [__] look at
this coming across a real scene here
that's a
wa what is this Rich Bounty of Dino
goodness Dino graveyard in here
yep yeah look at all this big Dino
meat whoa
oh we got a badass over here we do have
bad this come on Dino he's not ready for
your stabbing arms yeah here's one thing
they didn't teach you in Dino school
which is circle strafing stab circle
stra circle stra circle stra stab get
stabed oh get stab stab bunny hops some
bunny hops you got to keep him guessing
you can't do bunny hop okay that's okay
but I'm going to keep stabbing him in
the butt until he dies oh this circle
this next level Circle strafing you're
doing right now you think this Dino is
too big for me to kill uh are you
hitting it I think so I'm hitting its
soft Underside so far it just looks like
you're pissing it off real I think I am
I think I am pissing it off get dead
Dino I don't think the this must be how
dinosaurs died right cuz they were just
like little turds who couldn't fight
back dress part taught us anything okay
it's not working it's not working he's
look he's done with you no he's not done
with you he not done with he's not done
with you he's still ready to party
should I practice my Bas on him you
can he just knocked it right out of the
park wow that was Hubris home run is
what that I thought I could practice my
bis on him I know you didn't even want
to fight you were just like look I'm
above fighting this guy I'm going to use
you as target practice
I'm going to erase you from existence
good sir all right remember your place
in the food
chain going to make my spear when you
die do you leave behind one of those
stupid little boxes and you can go back
and pick up all your wood and sticks not
that I know of I don't know that seems
like it's something that's a little too
advanced for this game I mean look at me
carrying around this little this box
look at this look at
this look at this do you think that this
is a game with like a really advanced
like post death inventory system not yet
I'm carrying around a box on a leash
like it's my pet
box do you guys see my pet box anywh you
guys see my pet box I call him boxy old
boxy old boxy old boxy where'd you go
where'd you go old box my old
friend right make a spear I need to find
some more humans to kill SL dinos to
kill that uh so that dinosaur was
probably one of the bigger ones and
therefore I probably can't kill it on my
own okay cuz I think what you're
supposed to do is you're supposed to
like track dinosaur fights and find two
big dinosaurs fighting and then wait
till one kills the other and walks off
and then you just collect the remain and
get the spoils yeah and that's how you
get the big meat come in for
scraps all right make myself
a spear spear is the way to go I do I I
do wish that I uh could have tried my
bolus on some other human player
though oh you know don't count it out
just yet I'm sure they'll be back
they'll probably be back all right where
do you suppose that Cove is bet it's up
this way that sweet Cove that sweet Cove
we need some elevation is what we need
so we can survey our surroundings all
right and possibly identify where this
Cove is also I think at some point you
should swim out into the ocean and see
how far you can uh all right give that a
shot first I'm going to see if this is
the Cove take a little take a gander
this is definitely a bay of some sort
but is it a Cove do you think you're is
it a river Delta what uh uh uh so in the
map of the world because I assume this
is planet Earth you're playing on where
do you think this this
is it looks
like judging by I mean look at the you
know the well it's hard to say because
tophy over there yeah you've got
evergreen trees yeah right they're right
here yeah and then over here got palm
trees so this the well you know it's
like the
uh you know the theory of man coming out
of Africa we all used to be in one spot
and then we all like Pangia yeah the P
you know we all spread across the world
it's the same way with trees W origin oh
what's in here originally trees all
started in the same place and then they
two walked across the land bridge to
that seems F Canada that seems pretty
legit from Russia from Russia yeah there
was that Russia Canada land bridge yeah
the uh the the Trans Canada
freeway uh I'm not finding any players
Max what was in that box I that was that
was just a box of rocks that was like a
piece of wood okay great one or two oh
my God hey where do you think the the
cool stuff is in this
game used to typ that the chat hey guys
where's the cool stuff in this game cuz
so far I'm finding a lot of empty space
a lot of less cool stuff uh and not many
dinos where is it we need to find one of
those cave maybe hold on there was a map
we find a cave we should find a cave all
right there was AAP cave on this on this
Wiki cuz it was talking about the
healing and Cave well if you could find
a way to transpose that map to what
we're playing right here that would be
great because I can't make heads or
tails of any of this okay hold on that's
a Dyno over there all right I've got it
was a dino he
disappeared oh here we go here we go we
got a badass over here ready for this
here we go get dead I've got a Mah oh do
it do it he's trying to take Circ Circle
straight he's trying to take a little
nibble out of your oh this is one of
those Invincible dinos [__] oh into the
water into the water dinosaurs ultimate
weakness they can't swim dinosaurs can't
swim everyone knows dinosaurs can't swim
Evol they've evolved to adap to their
weaknesses oh no [__] I thought din
couldn't swim that's why Jurassic Park
was an island stay underneath the
dinosaur and he won't be able to bite
you because he can't his neck doesn't
work like that oh no oh look at him I
feel like he would have got your leg on
that one I think he's trying to kill me
I'm not sure he might drown he might
drown it seems like he'd be taking on a
lot of water keep open these fish are
willing to help me out in my time of
need and Desperation pray to the fish
Spirit you should have built that totem
should have built that totem you should
have built that totem and this wouldn't
be happening here I'm going to hide okay
I'm going to hide from the dino he's
never going to be able to see me I'm in
the Tall Grass I think I think it worked
actually yeah you see that what the hell
[__] you
dinosaur like how we just vanished I
just outsmarted you I just outsmarted
you and now I'll reap the benefits I'm
going to kill him that's what I'm going
to do Max you're not I'm going to kill
this guy I'm going to kill this son of a
[__]
dinosaur where you at Dino wa you're
back huh oh see if you can run across
this little Ro the land bridge this is
the land bridge okay [__] you just went
over a land bridge I don't actually I
don't see land bridge on the map oh the
jump is right click turns out I can jump
all right there's howling cave dinosaur
biggest weakness is sprinting around a
tree there's a lava cave in the middle
of the island all right we're definitely
going to hide from this Dyno I don't see
healing cave on here but but there are
some other caves if you want to go try
to find a different cave he's never
going to find me
the trick with Dinosaurs is to hide in
plain sight that's true all right okay
well it's because they can't see you if
you're not moving their vision is based
on movement remember Jurassic Park
you're so right their vision is based on
movement you're so right how did I not
even remember that my god I'm an idiot
that's all right though we're going to
do this okay so with that situation out
of the way we're going to find some uh
some buddies and I think we should start
a
tribe dinosaur are weak to
damage weak to damage yep let's see
where's my
chat I think you need to go I think he
need to go a
tribe we can call it A Tribe Called
Quest is that a reference that's a
reference it's like you never listened
to '90s Hip Hop I didn't listen to
enough of it apparently
all right where so where them Caves at
okay uh I mean it's very difficult for
me to orient to is it the river it's
there there are caves on one of the
rivers there are two rivers this is
seems like a pretty big GD River well
just oh I think I see it oh maybe that
is it over there I think that's a cave
over there right keep going keep going
over there okay I think this is the exit
to the howling cave so you might be able
to enter through that way or you might
have to go around a short distance all
right so first I need to make a torch
cuz I'm pretty pretty sure it's Pitch
Black in that cave all right should I
hunt for some fish is that a thing you
can do I don't know you tell me it looks
like I'm hunting for some fish right now
legs up in front of you like that's a
big one right
there this is how caveman fished back in
caveman times like he would exhaust
yourself like instantly doing this no
way I got oxygen for days bro okay I'm
going to make a I think got turned
around but you know what you're doing
over here that's the cave entrance first
things first I got to make myself a
torch cuz it's dark as hell in those
caves you think I need just one torch
you think that's enough uh I don't know
if I can make two
torches making a torch here we go we're
going to head in that cave that's what
we're going to
do oh
what I dropped my torch I thought I
could put the torch away in my my hidden
inventory turns out I can't in your
pants all right do you think that if you
fall into the water your torch will go
out okay okay there you go just skirt
around the edges
there oh here we go okay well I'm sure
there's trees in the cave yeah I'm sure
there's trees in this cave if I can okay
what the hell okay here we go here we go
all right and it's dark wait wait now
it's not okay all right what's
happening okay I think what's happening
is dark as hell in this cave underwater
by default has light but there's not
light in the cave oh God I'm so lost how
do I Orient myself people in the raining
in the cave you might not be able to see
what's going on in the cave but we can
see even less than you oh God we can
literally see nothing I think you need
to go around to the Rain cave entrance
all right where's the rain cave entrance
or the howling cave entrance rather okay
uh uh how do I get there from here okay
well look at this map here okay so you
see how the cave entrance is is there so
get on top of those rocks and just start
running towards the beach okay and
you'll go over a small mountain and then
you should reach the entrance to the
house I feel like that is just wait hold
on look look where the entrance is so if
that find the west then I feel like it's
generally this Direction I mean once you
H we head in this
direction it seems good I feel good
about this one Maxwell well you know let
your as a you know a man of the woods
let your survival
carry you yeah if you we can it looks
like you can access it from the beach so
if you get onto the beach it's not a
huge deal we can still get into we're
we're going to jump into a cave and then
we're going to find hidden cave [__]
like diamonds and dead splunkers yeah
that kind of stuff I feel like it's
probably this waych mech's going to be
down in there kyama might be okay so I
think it's going to be this way and then
like a little to your left it's going to
be like over that hill or something all
right here we go let me switch my spear
just
in
case maybe it's F farther up you think
it's further up might be farther up
might not be I don't know no yeah don't
keep going you should be able to see the
the Cave the entrance oh no oh oh no I
think these guys are probably camped out
by the cave they probably are you I've
come across a situation all right you
know what how do you high ground High
Ground there you go take The High Ground
put a little bit of elevation between me
and my foes potential foes I don't know
if they may be friend I would wage wager
uh dollars to Donuts that that Tepe is
right this guy okay this guy okay he's
got a sweet Shield you that guy has a
baller Shield he has a baller sh no harm
Crouch down should I hide flat on your
belly should I hide yeah all right let
me hide in here see if you can tactical
stealth Espionage this
guy there you go there we go go here we
go oh this is so good yeah this is so
good and now get him with the sneak
attack get him with the sneak attack s
it's a perfect crime get him with the
sneak attack stay in the grass guy stay
in the grass can't see me he might be
behind you you think he's behind me I
mean he probably ran he probably ran
deeper into the woods to try to catch
you all right just go just go just go
just go we got to get to the cave we our
objective here is to get to the cave
entrance not kill oh he's back down
there well just look around just look
around see if you see the cave entrance
you think it's here it kind of looks
like it would be there it looks like
it's right down here it kind of looks
like it's right down there
all right quick into the cave in the
cave there's shelter in the cave there's
shelter in the cave oh but I don't have
a torch uh oh but that's a glowing thing
get that glowing thing I think that's a
healing
herb all right I got it that thing
okay I need a torch I need to go craft
myself a torch oh oh wow that's some
spooky stuff right there some spooky
[__] although it might be do you think
he's in darkness yet I don't know he's
probably just waiting for you to come
out because he knows you're not oh and
sweet Shield guys there too no [__] just
hold hold your ground hold your ground
hold your ground if they had a torch
it's likely they would have it out and
it would illuminate everything I would
hope so but they must not have a torch
out so they can't see you no they can't
but you can see them in
silhouette you can taunt them in the
chat a little bit rile them up yeah I
should do that tell them you are the
Knight do the Batman thing you are
Vengeance you are the
Knight see that guy he walked right up
to you but then left I don't know maybe
he sees you maybe he doesn't this is
really good your whole Bane monologue
You' got going on in chat I hope people
in the twitch are able to
see
all right I feel like they've this is my
chance for
escape Easy Does It Easy Does It be
ready to be ready to retreat into the
cover of
Darkness all right all right there you
go there you go there you go bail bail
Smash and grab Smash and grab this was
this was a real smash and grab
operation like can you can you can you
climb up that sheer surface I want to I
want to make a I want to make a torch I
want to make a torch and go back in
there oh my God they're going to find
you and you're going to lose your
healing herb I don't even know what that
healing herb does it lets you tame
dinosaurs are you sure yes that's how
you do it you kill the dinosaur okay you
pull out the healing herb you're like oh
sorry I murdered you you give him the
healing herb it comes back to life and
it's your buddy think so
well no well no you've got the torch go
back in the cave now oh my
God I want to see what's in this cave
went through the whole process of doing
the torch although they are going to see
you so quickly they're going to see me
super
fast all right into the cave I can
always just drop the torch that's true
and instantly have the veil Darkness
this is some Dark Souls [__] happening
this is some Dark Souls
business this
uh hold on there's a the exit to the
cave is back by the lake so there must
be some sort of route through
it just follow the wind just follow the
wind listen to your
heart do a barrel roll a barrel oh uhoh
uhoh somebody's leaving markers for
themselves I think that person is
taunting
me know if you stare into the darkness
the darkness stares back at
you that's not a bane
line now you have my permission to die
your punishment must be more
severe oh I can't see anything I regret
coming into this cave this is a [__]
ass cave might not have been the best
there's nothing in here it's like a
Barren cave in here you need to oh now
it's [__] water now my torch is going
to go out yeah it's kind of a bad scene
I'm lost it's bad scene no no no no no
no we're going to get to the end I feel
like you're making progress and the cave
really isn't that big although I feel
you are going to have to enter a source
of water to reach the exit I'm trying to
oh no yeah okay
well well I well now we're in a pickle I
can always find my way out via MH the
illuminated nature of being underwater
that's true but there wasn't a waterway
that led to the entrance but there is
one that leads to the exit yeah assuming
you're in the correct line oh I'm boned
I'm going to have to Suicide down here
I'm going to have to drown myself I'm
doing it I'm doing it doing a sweet
drowning death by Drowning is this even
going to happen W I can really survive a
long time guy in the chat says this game
hasn't heard from its developer in about
four
weeks bad time a Eric Tay really wants
the ER for one thing Eric's making fun
of you for blowing out your own torch
and he's chastising you for not killing
those four guys what how was I going to
kill those four guys I'm but one dude
and they're a tiny Army of
men all right let's see what should I do
now I feel like I've pretty much maxed
out what I uh there's a lava cave I bet
that's maybe has a little bit more
brightness in it cuz lava is bright
that's true so you could try that
otherwise there's nowhere pretty much no
fire I'm going to go make some friends
oh this is it this is where the human CA
trafficking thing was remember this is
where the guy took you cuz it was it was
the river and the rocks in
between what if I hide in his fire yeah
and when he comes back and roast your
chestnuts just roasted my
chestnuts all right do you think he's
around here I don't know he tore down
his tent off a quick there you go hi I'm
hiding see if he comes back see if he
comes out is he coming back and then how
great would it be if I just popped out
of the fire his face that would be the
perfect that would be pretty good
although I feel like he's not coming
back anytime you could do some bow and
arrow stuff we haven't seen the bow and
arrow yet should I make a bow and arrow
you can make a bow and arrow bow and
arrow what do I need for bow and
arrow some wood and some rocks how much
of each hold on my this thing does not
want to play ball with me right now oh
here we go okay let me get back up to
the top of the page where's my thing
there it is and the bow and arrow
there's arrows the bow is five wood to
two Stone okay and then arrows are just
two wood
right how many arrows should I make
enough well I wonder if it makes them in
batches or if it makes them one at a
time I really hope it's one at a time
knowing The Stomping Land y as we do
having played this game for about 45
minutes now y I feel like it it's going
to be like a really lengthy crafting
process for a single
Arrow
there you go you're a little off the
mark there fine it's fine you've got
gumption it's the spirit of the process
that's right spear guy you think they're
spe guy oh here we go you're not spear
guy though I got 10 oh you get 10 you
get 10 try a little we're going to try a
little target practice target practice
get get a feel for it spear guy is not
first person cool with this guy being
behind him all right feeling pretty good
about this bow and arrow sitch we're
going to go find
somebody but where do who do you think
they
are you think I can kill a dinosaur with
bow and arrows surely I mean I killed a
dinosaur how do you think prehistoric
man killed dinosaurs they didn't have
guns well obviously they killed
dinosaurs they didn't have Anthrax by
Circle strafing them and then barely
grazing them with their Spear and then
just tickling them TI a little bit
little tickle little under tickle and
then they instantly die I mean that's
how I killed dinosaur they tipped right
over they tipped right over they scooped
the stakes out of them where are the bad
man at
we got to go back to that uh Beachside
Fort yeah the uh the Cave the Cave cave
yeah cave cave let's see so if I mean if
you follow the ri well no the river is
if you had followed that River it
wouldn't have taken you to the where you
wanted to go uh I feel like oh yeah you
are out in the middle of nowhere am I if
you're cuz yeah you're like over here
now oh balls there's got to be some I
want to find that uh lava there's Lake
lava cave if you follow the river it'll
take you pretty close to the like if you
go follow the river through here it'll
take you pretty close to the or as close
as you're going to get to the lava cave
entrance then you have to go up some
mountains yeah there's not much
happening in this game not going on a
whole hell of a lot all right how much
time do we have left we got about 9
Minutes N9 minutes all right what should
I try to do within my 9 Minutes well you
got that bow and arrow I got the bow and
arrow so I'm going try to kill something
yeah try to just justos try to murder
death something yeah whether it's a
dinosur or a man I'm going to kill
something something's going to happen
here it's too bad you haven't been
killed by a man on a dinosaur yeah
that'd be pretty baller yeah that would
be
cool I haven't seen this game a prequel
to turo you think oh yeah you think this
game and turo take place in the same
universe I would imagine a un a universe
where man and dinosaurs co-mingle
together was there an expanded universe
for turo it seems like somebody would
have done like a a really terrible like
six issue miniseries do a search for
turoc fanfiction okay hold on let me
pull something up here all right I found
the river again so that's all right so
it just started raining and you'll
notice that it cut really light out yep
it's because the the rain gives off
steam and then the light is reflected
off of water moist moisture that is so
smart can't believe I didn't think about
that I just all right so here we got a
water Dyno I'm going to shoot the [__]
out of it Amo what up W water Dino get
dead
all right these
dinos they're all fighting in the exact
same spot I found them last time I want
to point that
out seems like you can just kind of
predict where dinos are going to be I
was going to read this poem about turac
that I found on F fiction.net but it is
super long you should read it read it
while I'm running to uh something okay
hang on
uh oh
boy it's really long okay here we go
here we go this is going to read some
turac uh fanfiction poetry while I'm
running to try to find goddamned
anything in The Stomping Land This is a
turac reum for a kill
okay the Beast lies before me dripping
foul smelling saliva its clawed toes
scrape the ground foul smelling thing
the Beast continues to Lurch towards me
attracted to my aura I draw forth my
knife another one comes circl me like a
ring like rings do two now I face demon
lizards of pure blood lust eyes piercing
like a ray of Darkness a roar of hunger
survival a must the two lunge but both
do only
myth the speed of a hunter faster than
Beast I dive my blade into the Flesh of
hold on L my spot one of the other okay
I'm about to dive my arrow into this
Dino oh did did you find a dino hold
on get dead going to write you a
dinosaur reum I'll pause while you do
this okay and you're dead kill double
kill double kill look at that beautiful
we got a few more minutes you can keep
reading oh wait revive me oh no come on
oh he's gonna he's just gonna lay on the
dead dinosaur
body all right where was I yeah I drive
my blade into the Flesh of one the other
looks looking longing rather for Feast
then just so happened that oh sorry that
just so happened to gut the other lizard
until life there was none the other
Roars anger and its call I take them uh
I take from the dead one my bloodstained
knife the other runs at me ready to Maul
but its head meets my blade ending its
life thinking it's over I turn but to
see the Tyrant the king drawn by the
blood would normally scare and cause
others to flee uh where are we but not I
as courage fills me like a flood a
shotgun too small a pistol too weak a
fusion Cannon would nail him to the wall
but make this Hunter seem Mighty Meek
the weapon I've chosen the one I have
made formed from the Pieces Of Eight
fire oh fires a blue beam of power as
thin and pierces as a blade sure why not
and puts this Tyrant King extinct in
this date so left with nothing but the
bodies of the dead and weary from the
slaughter of lizards all sizes I must
lay down my head and begin with the moon
sets and the sun
rises [__] all right I think that's a
good point to end this stream on and
that was turac reim for that was turac
recum for a kill which you can find on
fanfiction find on fanfiction.net it was
the second thing that was on the TAC
fanfiction page so that was uh that was
The Stomping
Land um I I don't know if I can
recommend this game in its current state
yeah it's a little it's a little rough
it's a little rough it's a little Bare
Bones uh dinosaurs are a cool idea but
it seems like this one has a way to go
uh but it is steam Early Access so
supposedly it's going to be updated
maybe if the development maybe it's been
a little while I think since the last
update of
hibernation yeah that's a no that's what
bears do oh that's
very different similar creatures but
actually quite different when you get
right down to it anyways that's been it
for today's episode of the Sha method we
have another show coming on later today
yes 2 p.m. Pacific time which is in
about two hours yeah just about uh check
out the lobby we'll have a whole bunch
of cool stuff we're going to talk about
the road to the game of the year right
our favorite games from the first half
of 2014 and what we're looking forward
to going forward with the rest of the
year so there you have it guys thank you
very much for watching on behalf of
Maxwell McGee thank you thanks for
watching we'll see you
later